[Musique]
je sais que j'ai dans un mauvais plan et
c'est une galère en sac régnier bien
alors je suçais jose nacho et puis
j'étais rencontrer on gadjos assurée
bien ce que j'étais bien crever lui pour
acheter mon coeur voilà c'est ultra
disait ça maintenant langage clair pas
dire quoi ça veut dire j'étais je
m'emmerdais ou bien je veux dire j'étais
avec des gens qui qui m'angoisse un peu
puis un sein c'est la galère ouais
et puis alors je suis parti j'étais
rejoindre des copains je suis parti
c'est je suis
et puis j'ai toujours mon gars tu
joueras engageant donc c'est très
dynamique un mois ça ça et ça serait
bien
c'est bien c'était où c'était mieux
coeur c'était vrai qu'avec ce qui s'est
passé et bien après c'était y'a pas il
n'y a pas de mots pour ce qui s'est
passé
comment tu te sens devant la caméra je
me sens mal parce que j'ai l'impression
d'être devant dès condé on est surveillé
quoi et quand b et condé des cov quoi
les causes ou bouche par mois de jesse
james
ça veut dire pas des cons et que ça veut
dire des flics on a les glandes
ah ouais ça on a les boules c'est une
expression qui veut dire que c'est pas
bien quoi avoir les boules c'est être
mal à l'aise quoi c'est d'avoir quelque
chose ici quoi au contraire avoir du
plaisir c'est comme on dit ça je me la
donne quoi c'est très dur je me la donne
je m'amuse mais teulet mois la donne pas
je le cnra il semble pas vraiment dense
dans ce contexte donc par exemple un
concert de rock et après tu veux dire
aux jeunes bien de nous je me souviens
donner à ce concert et fripés cinq mots
qu'on entend souvent dire privé ça veut
dire avoir peur un peu fit penser qu'on
est dans une situation qui nous met mal
à l'aise en flip comme un flipper quand
on est sur les nerfs
et est-ce que c'est flippant quand on
est amoureux
pas du tout c'est en sait comment ces
humbles yab iab et est bien c'est bien
si tu es amoureux d'une fille a pu
étudier comment tu croques je suis
morgan d'une fille d'une gadji plus tôt
gadji gadjo et ça existe au masculin
c'est moi la wii gadjo un pai dubaï
alors voilà je sois parce que c'est
compliqué ça un gadjo à paille
une paille une meuf vainqueur
neuf jeunes filles oui une femme une
femme un gadjo c'est un mec un kama
nascar
quelle est la preuve
ça fait peur enfin si je t'en prie
charlatans les ont d'abord ici à faire
là jamais être amoureux raccroc morgan
[Musique]
nous avait dit ça sur ce monde ça veut
dire quoi ça sur way ses besoins de sa
crasse et bien c'est qu'ils sont
bienvenus
ils s'envoleront d'user compenser au
mieux ça craint craignos craignos où ça
creuse grignotent aussi autrement dit on
regarde et regarde quelque chose je
souffre je souffre tellement demain matt
m'a dit matt m'a tu vas t'en peux dire
je shove tu chauffes il chauffe non non
on dit simplement chouf
c'est un impératif à l'imparfait du
subjonctif ça ne marche pas la presse et
les fraudes
le bout d'un gros bonnet le petit bonne
voie la base en faveur d'un super beau
mais ça allait les robert laisse un
vieux salaires on sait pas trop mais
rien inventé du tout
les doudounes chine aussi ses vieux moi
j'ai plein sont ont fait beaucoup de
verlan dans le notre langage elle pas
mal de verlan un match car ça veut dire
pas arrête vatan c'est fini gage les
gages de ce mot gage d dégage le gage
des revers lens
nadja ce bizarre une chance j'attends
des gitans ces gitans comme les mots
comme gadji gadjo c'est un peu des
origines gitanes jusqu'à des mots
autrement qu'ils sont une veine très à
la mode
wallace place car pour des pour désigner
un gadjo un homme passe car cela donnait
aussi c'est ça se voit sur est assurée
assure et rassure et ça veut dire assuré
sur le réseau que assure pas trop encore
à l'aja sur pas vraiment toi les caméras
c'est pas je suis mal à l'aise un peu ah
ouais quand tu dirais ça de l'eau doit
sûrement fait deux morts
[Musique]